I was teaching at university of texas
and i was teaching a class and
interactive design and this was in the
sort of late 90s and the internet had
had gotten really big and my students
were grappling with notions of interface
design and really trying to figure out
how to how do they engage users and so I
brought in a project where we began to
study games and the students began to
design and redesign games as a way to
understand what is good interactive
design and that is the first time that
I'd actually brought games into my own
classroom space and the first time that
I took people who'd never done game
design and put them in the role of a
game designer and it was a huge moment
of discovery for me because my students
learn more about how to engage an
audience how to really communicate and
and how to create really interesting
unusual kinds of spaces when they used
game design as a starting point even
though they weren't designing games
eventually the process of thinking like
a game designer gave them a whole tool
sets toolset that they hadn't had
previously and so that sort of set me
along this path where I began to say you
know there's something just interesting
in this act of teaching people to design
games and then I begin to work with kids
and one of the most interesting thing
that happens when you work with young
people in designing games is how deep
they go into the content and so this is
this question of where the math and
science stuff might come in
when we look at kids and we talked about
that definition of who is a gamer it's
actually a really old definition there
it used to be a time when only a certain
population of kids played games they
tended to be boys and I tended to be
kind of geeky boys that were hidden away
in their basement the truth is today
when you look at who is playing games
particularly younger kids up to about
sixth or seventh grade it's all kids and
most kids don't self-identify themselves
as gamers if you ask them about that
identity it's just something that they
do so there's an assumption when we
recruit kids for the school that that
all kids have to a greater or lesser
degree some experience playing games and
an interest in playing games the school
is not excuse me it's not a vocational
school that's intended to graduate game
designers so that isn't actually any way
that we talk about the school and so the
kids that we get our kids that are
deeply interested in a school that might
feel a little bit different than a
traditional school they tend to be
really creative kids that are interested
in ideas that they'll have a chance to
design stuff and make stuff their kids
that tend to be you know in some sense
high-performing and having strong
interests and those interests don't
necessarily have to be games but they
might be interested in reading or they
might be interested in sports but their
kids that get passionate about something
and get excited about a school that
might help them cultivate that passion
so with the model at Quest is that the
teachers collaborate with game designers
to design the curriculum so there's no
expectation that teachers have to be
game designers in the way that there's
no expectation that the game designers
are going to be in the classroom
teaching day to day with the kids so the
teachers that we recruited mostly came
from the public school system we have a
couple that taught at private schools
previously none of them had a game
design background a few of them had an
interesting games some of them had a
background in technology but all of them
were strong collaborators had worked in
contexts where collaboration was key all
of them were deeply interested in the
craft of learning and and how to really
work with kids and all of them were open
to the idea of being a curriculum
designer and working with game designers
and trying to see where this model could
could really take learning for kids
I would say that it's it's not so much
among our parents because any open house
or talk that they might come to where
they hear about the school becomes
really clear how we're talking about
games and how we value them but there is
a larger cultural discourse that I think
is quite limited around this issue of
what's the value of games and what's the
value of play and video games in
particular because they've been covered
I think historically in the media as
either games that are about violence or
games that are about wasting time those
are the two kind of dominant narratives
that people that don't know much about
games here again and again and again and
so it's a bit of a default position that
people fall into just because they
haven't perhaps really thought about it
any parent that that we have that has a
child that spends an amount of time
gaming at home actually understands
something about why that child is gaming
and what they're getting out of it and
partially it is because they talk to the
kids and those reasons really vary
sometimes the the value of the gaming is
around the the social structure in the
community that the kids have we find
that that gaming is less about the
artifact of the game itself and more
about the community that sort of sits
around that game and that players are
part of and for many parents that social
piece is pretty big for kids for other
parents there is a opportunity around
creativity that they see happening in
these games they also see their kids
persisting on problems and games that
they don't see them persisting on in
other spaces and they begin to recognize
that that persistence and tenacity is
actually something pretty important they
don't really know how to make it happen
in other kinds of spaces but they they
see their kids doing that and they think
wow if i can get my kid to do that when
they're working on math be that
persistent there's something really
valuable there so I think it's more this
general cultural dialogue that's pretty
pretty narrow and pretty underdeveloped
at the moment and part of the goal of
this school as well as some you know a
lot of other people doing work
the space is to try to complex ified
argument and begin to understand that
you know historically from the moment
that human beings sort of came into
existence play was a part of culture it
was a profound part of what makes us
human a profound part of what keeps a
community together a profound part of
ways in which we can deal with complex
issues that are maybe too complicated to
deal with outside a kind of play space
and so the notion and value of play
historically has been huge and it
doesn't make sense to me today why we
would dismiss it because it's something
that we see embodied in a way that maybe
we don't understanding and understand in
some digital games that for many people
look kind of scary